welcome back to Las Vegas now did you
gain the quarantine 15 if you did you're
not alone our friends at image Medspa
want to make you make you feel good on
the outside and on the inside as we
emerge from our homes to poolside also
keep in mind this segment was done prior
to cope at nineteen and new safety
measures are now in place take a look
yeah definitely getting tighter your
duct your definitely tightening up for
sure and you're definitely losing that
I've softened up a lot last trick back
that's what you call it results after
saying no to CoolSculpting and yes to
cryo tea shop with Skyler over at image
Med Spa and it's actually going to do a
full customized treatment that's what I
like about the coyote shark close
scoping are set applicators that are set
for 35 minutes and I only treat what's
set into that whole scoping applicator
where this is actually doing the full
entire abdomen so we're clicking Mel
we're clicking abdomen the cryo tea
shock or a cryo thermogenic machine can
actually do fat removal and skin
tightening the reason why it can do
those is because after you lose the fat
you actually want to tighten and tone up
that skin and I'm gonna hit the start
button and it's automatically gonna go
to read that first keeps up the fat
cells raises them to the surface and
then we are gonna go ahead and freeze
those suckers away so what is it feel
like so it feels like a massage kind of
like a instead of a hot stone maybe it's
like a cold stone massage so image
client Chris that he works out but
because of genetics he just can't seem
to get rid of that stubborn fat in his
stomach and his love handles he is
getting the treatment to get summer
ready as you can see we just went from
red to blue which now is starting the
cold after about one to two minutes he's
actually going to be numb he's not even
gonna feel the pinching are you feeling
the pinching as it is and overall this
is actually freezing and crystallizing
the fat this is the second step to t
shock so we are pinching and then we're
holding the cold air and it's doing like
what a suction applicator if
CoolSculpting does although it's getting
more of an even texture on average a
client needs three to six sessions a tea
shock for the best results that kills
about 38 to 40 percent of fat cells in
the treated area once they're gone
they're gone for good a lot of people
don't realize that you're set with a
certain amount of fat cells and you stop
producing it adolescent
so when you gain weight they're just
expanding and when you lose weight
they're just shrinking so this is a true
non-invasive alternative to liposuction
and there's no downtime most people can
just casually come in on a lunch break
or right after work image med spas hours
cater to everyone you can come in as
early as 8:30 a.m. in the morning and we
find ourself freezing fat until like 12
sometimes 1 or 2 in the morning it's
also totally safe and only targets your
fat cells we're not touching any other
organs or anything it's actually going
after the fat and the fat only so it's
selectively killing about self-image med
spies all about boosting that double
image the one on the outside and on the
inside they offer a variety of services
to help image Medspa is actually a
one-stop shop we offer everything that
treats from head-to-toe from starting
out at teeth whitening to Botox and
fillers fat reductions cellulite
reduction skin tightening treatments
hair removal and then as far as like
dinner we're talking about like medical
weight loss testosterone therapy we've
got a solution for almost everything all
right Thank You Skylar for more
information call 702 nine seven two nine
four six six or just head to image
Medspa comm we'll be right back